today i'm going to be speaking with
matthew stewart who's a philosopher and
author of several books including most
recently the 9.9 percent the new
aristocracy that is entrenching
inequality and warping our culture uh
really appreciate having you on matthew
thank you
yeah it's great to be here david thanks
for having me so we often hear about the
one percent we hear about the 0.1
percent uh we hear about the bottom 90
percent many times or the bottom 50 in
discussions of of economics and society
and culture
what is significant about this 9.9
that made you want to study and write
about it specifically
so let's not forget that the 0.1 is
actually driving the wealth inequality
and the bottom 90 is the group that's
losing so the
there's two interesting things about the
9.9 percent one is that it's actually
holding on to its wealth so that's i
think really important
and then the other thing is that it
plays a much bigger role in driving our
our values and our culture
so that's i think what makes them
especially interesting because i think
we're all part of it even if we're not
financially part of it can you talk
about the ways in which that group
drives culture
yeah i mean so for example uh in
education it's pretty straightforward um
you know the the the plan for for making
it into the point nine percent um today
is to is to go to college and go to a
good college and get a good degree and
so on um and that kind of plan made a
lot of sense when college was
inexpensive when a lot of it was
publicly paid for um and when there were
jobs for people who got those kind of
degrees but all those realities are gone
and yet the value system is if anything
even more entrenched so there's even
more emphasis on you can make it if you
just go to the right college and sort of
figure out how the system works and then
it turns out of course that the people
who succeed in that are the ones who
already start with a leg up whose
parents are already in the 9.9 percent
what are the um economic uh just what
what what's the line for entering that
group that 9.9 in terms of where is the
90th percentile in terms of income and
wealth and where how far up does it
reach
yeah so um but let me also just qualify
and say that you know we don't get too
fetishized about the numbers because
they move and also it's not just about
the numbers it's about relative
proportions but um you know basically
you you need about 1.2 million dollars
in net worth to make it into the top 10
decile or the 9.9 of the wealth
distribution
um and your income should be in 120 000
um plus range so that's what kind of
gets you into it financially and then at
the top end um obviously it's it's
different as you get to the top but
about 20 million will push you out the
top
uh in in wealth and you know sort of um
uh 500 000 or so in income which you
know sounds like a lot but in fact when
you compare it to the very large suns
they're going into the 0.1 it's actually
pretty small so it's a group is more
homogeneous than people like to think
now what's interesting is certainly
i would guess the vast majority of the
bottom half of that group would consider
themselves middle class and many who
live in the most
expensive cities would would absolutely
insist that that they are middle class
is that part is that culturally relevant
that so much of that group considers
itself middle class and is it accurate
in some sense
yeah so what's happening is is the
hollowing out of the middle class but
the ideas are about
you know 20 or 30 years behind the
economic reality so um
a lot of people in in this 9.9 percent
even in the bottom part they don't get
how wealthy they are relative to the
rest of society they don't quite get
um how um how much better they do have
it and of course part of the reason why
i don't get it is because they're also
being stressed i mean it's pretty hard
to stay in that group you have to work
really hard
um and you know get some lucky breaks
and be in the right place at the right
time and so on so
um
i think there's a significant um
misperception in in the group which is
how wealthy they are and a lot of this
shows up in surveys you ask people you
know how much do the people at the top
make and they say oh wow you know the
average ceo makes million dollars a year
and of course that's that's preposterous
and the average ceo makes 17 or 18
million dollars a year for a top 500
company so um
i think there's a lot of misperceptions
and the one you mentioned the middle
class delusion is is really big one
can you talk a little bit about the
racial makeup of this group that you're
describing generally speaking
yeah and pretty simply it's mostly white
i mean um
it's about 90 white um as against you
know depends how you measure at 65 to 70
of the general population
um there definitely are
uh people of color uh in in in the 9.9
percent a significant group but in
relative to the representation in the
total population it's significantly
lower so um i think the black shares
about 1.7
of the 9.9 as against about 13 of the
general population latinos roughly
similar
in terms of um political power i mean we
understand the dynamics of money and
political power in the united states
generally speaking
but that top 9.9
is much
bigger in terms of population by
definition than the top 0.1 percent in
terms of aggregate power and that
doesn't mean it's being wielded
effectively but in terms of aggregate
power what is the power dynamic between
that top 0.1 and the following 9.9
yes it's um the 9.9 presents this big
political problem especially for the
democratic party frankly because
um that group now is is leaning
uh blue it's not completely rude but
it's more so than the general population
whereas the top 0.1
uh notwithstanding all the
nonsense of ultimate liberals actually
functionally leans very much to the
right
and
and the dynamic between them it's a
really great question it's
you know on the one hand 9.9 is
fundamentally dependent on the 0.1
percent uh economically but on the other
hand culturally
um
there is a big gap and a significant
part shifting left is aware of that and
tries to pull away the big danger for um
the democratic party and the left
is that
this
group which is i think has a
disproportionate weight in left
politics um
doesn't necessarily understand or share
the interests of the other 90 of the
population
so they they tend to skew
the left in ways that can be um
ultimately
go against the interests of the large
part of the population and sort of work
indirectly for the top oh that's
interesting so let's see if we can think
about that a little so you've got so the
top 0.1 percent is
leans overtly to the republican side
and it's sort of clear that the economic
interests of that group in terms of the
policy they want is not good for the
bottom 90
it sounds like you're saying with this
the following 9.9 percent nominally
these are folks who identify
more as democrats than republicans and
believe themselves to lean more left
than they lean right
but maybe without even really knowing it
the policies they want or the status quo
that they reinforce is also not good for
that bottom ninety percent
yeah i mean a classic example for me is
is the real estate game so the um uh
we don't actually pay a lot of attention
to that this issue in national politics
but it actually drives a lot of our
culture and it drives a lot of the
issues that we have this the the huge
segregation economic and racial
in our neighborhoods and the the role of
the 9.9 and that i would say on
aggregate is really pretty regressive
because what it ends up doing is is
saying oh the issue isn't you know our
neighborhoods the issue is has to do
with um you know any number of other
things you know personal prejudices with
education with
um you know economic policies that we're
that interest us more but in fact the
9.9 tends to ultimately come down very
heavily in favor of very restrictive
zoning um and other very restrictive
land use policies that that drive up the
price of housing that have created an
affordability housing crisis that
reinforce segregation dynamics that
reinforce educational segregation
dynamics um and so they end up being you
know very regressive and it's something
that the 9.9 percent i think
intellectually the more self-aware
members are are on to this but
uh functionally the way they actually
act um ends up you know reproducing
these these divisions that in turn
increase in equality and work to the
benefit of the 0.1 percent one of the
things that often comes up in
conversation with people who do well but
are not in the top 0.1 percent and maybe
not even in the top 1 percent so maybe
we're talking about
90th to 98th percentile to kind of
imagine again you know as we're talking
about these are not exact exact
delineations but there's often the
feeling among the 90 to 98 percent that
hey
the very top doesn't pay enough in taxes
and we do need to do things for the
bottom 90
but also the taxes are a little too high
on us the 90 to the 98. can you talk a
little bit about
that dynamic and and really
where some of these lines should be in
terms of taxation
yeah so there there's a grain of truth
in that it turns out that the
the real tax rate when you throw it all
in you have the federal state local you
look at capital over an income and so on
the real tax rate for the at the very
top is lower it's it's dramatically and
absurdly lower than it is for the upper
middle class and so on so vis-a-vis the
0.1 yeah the 9.9 is getting screwed like
the rest of society um there's another
side of it though that's a little harder
for people than 9.9 to grasp and that's
that
our tax system is so um arcane and
complicated that it ends up indirectly
subsidizing a lot of people invisibly so
you know a classic case point is the
mortgage interest deduction
but there are many other bits and pieces
like that that have the effect of um
subsidizing the 9.9 percent
in ways that are kind of invisible so
people in that group
think that their taxes are actually
higher than they are
um another going back to real estate
that's another kind of invisible subsidy
we have um
we not withstanding the fact that we do
have property uh municipal property
taxes we basically don't capture the the
implicit rental value of real estate and
so people who own their own homes end up
getting an indirect tax subsidy but
they're completely unaware of this
they think they're geniuses for having
bought into the real estate market when
they did and so they're they're kind of
unaware that some of the money that's
coming their way is really an indirect
tax subsidy so it's a really complicated
picture and of course you know i'm sure
you'd agree if we could wave magic want
we'd replace the current taxes to have
something radically more progressive
and a lot more fair yeah i've had very
interesting conversations with folks who
say
you know i don't really make that much
and i'm touching the 33 federal tax
bracket and then when i live if i live
in new york or california or
massachusetts then you're throwing five
to five to ten percent on top of that
and i'll often say to these folks listen
you don't have to tell me exactly what
you make but
understand that you're touching that top
33 percent but not all of your income is
taxed at that because we have you know
these are these are brackets uh marginal
tax brackets and then you've got your
standard deduction
um and you have a mortgage and you've
got you know all these different things
you should really look at that first
page of your 1040 which says total tax
divide it by your income and you are
going to find a shockingly low number
and many times it's 17 18
federally overall
and the these are folks absolutely in
that 9.9 percent who themselves don't
really have an understanding of the
degree to which they are paying federal
taxes
yeah but
but let's just not forget that you know
the big money is at the very top of
course and the big solution here
absolutely is actually to go after this
yeah yeah another two or three points
for someone making a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars a year has almost no
impact compared to what we're talking
about in the point one percent without a
doubt
right right but then let me also mention
on the other end because this is
something that happens when we talk
about the 9.9 we forget about people
that are at the at the other end of the
economic spectrum um
we don't think about sales taxes as a
big issue generally if you're remember
the 9.9 but that's actually a pretty
significant hit to a lot of um people
with lower incomes um we don't think
about the um the fica you know the the
uh payroll tax deduction but that you
know if you've got if you've got a
minimum wage job that's a big big chunk
of your income so um things are are much
more regressive than than people
understand in the 9.9
without question um the book is
fascinating it's called the 9.9 the new
aristocracy that is entrenching
inequality and warping our culture we've
been speaking with the book's author
matthew stewart really appreciate your
time today
yeah great to be here david thank you